good morning john about 12 000 years ago
some people started to get really good
at controlling the plants that made
their food they would take care of them
they'd move them around and water them
and remove their competition and they
started to plant seeds from the plants
that were just a little bit better they
were a little easier to take care of
they made some more food they tasted a
little bit better that kind of thing
choosing something that was a little bit
better and then a little bit better than
a little bit better it made things a lot
better over the long term this is one of
my favorite examples uh that's just the
tip of some grass that you're looking at
right now and that we selected into this
giant hunk and crunch of sweetness this
is usually called artificial selection
but i think that might be a term that we
eventually move past because like we're
not fake we're just human but also
because the term artificial selection
makes a little less sense when you
notice that there are cases of
unintentional evolution through human
selection let's talk about it one of the
ways we take care of crops is we
eliminate their competition we pull up
weeds but you can't ever pull up all of
the weeds and you are least likely to
pull up the weeds that look a little bit
like your crop because you don't want to
pull up your crop and so the weeds that
looked the most like their crops were
most likely to get left and then their
offspring would look more like the crop
and the ones that looked the most like
the crop would be most likely to
procreate you see where we're going here
eventually you end up with a weed that
looks almost entirely like your crop
plants that do this are called
vavalovian mimics named after the guy
who first figured this all out and
valvolovian mimics remain to this day a
problem as an example camelina sativa is
a plant that is also sometimes called
false flax kind of impractical to
separate them out in the field so we
ended up separating out the seeds making
sure we only planted flaxseed in the
field we created big machines and a lot
of infrastructure to do this and you
know what happened we created a new
evolutionary pressure to have false flax
seeds look and act to that machine
exactly like flax seed so now the
machines can't tell false flax seeds
from flax seeds
what a gigantic pain in the butt john i
sometimes worry that we look at our
world and we only see the problems it
makes sense that we would do this if
you're a flax farmer you have to think
about false flax a lot but false flax is
a problem that was created by a solution
that solution being agriculture and
agriculture safe to say has created a
lot of problems but it's also solved a
lot of problems including probably the
biggest problem an individual human can
have which is the i don't want to watch
my child starve problem solving problems
creates new problems like the last
hundred years of remarkable increases in
quality of life and increases in the
value we place on human lives would not
have been possible without coal and oil
and gas and those fuels created a huge
number of problems some of which we
solved some of which
are going to require us to stop using
them in order to solve global warming is
not a problem that was created by evil
it's a problem that was created by
people solving problems i was listening
to the ezra klein show a couple weeks
ago and maggie nelson said uh something
that i don't know if i've ever heard a
more true thing said more beautifully
she said that people right now have a
deep hunger for a tool with no blood on
it and i do i do but i don't know
that that exists
i don't know that it can exist the world
is messy and we need to stop thinking
that we can survive in it without doing
any harm we need to find ways to
mitigate the harm and ways to solve the
problems we also need to understand that
the solutions to those problems will
create yet more problems the internet is
an amazing solution that has created a
lot of problems i wanted it to be a tool
with no blood on it it is not but the
human experiment that we are all a part
of is not an attempt to arrive at
perfect it has always been and will
always be an attempt to select for a
world that is just a little bit better
than it was before john i'll see you on
tuesday
p.s john cause i know you weren't gonna
let me get away with this my cat's name
is gummy bear which is the decision that
oren made and it's a cute name because
it's like cute and bouncy but also
secretly i like it because a good
nickname for a cat named gummy bear
remains goburker which i do still
sometimes call him bit of a heavy video
to end with a cat name but look the
human experience is varied and and and
we celebrate that